back together a day when we can
celebrate
every baby shower and baptism and
birthday that we missed
we can finally wrap our arms around
loved ones
and we know vaccinations are the key to
that
with dodger stadium we are throwing open
the door to that future
this mega site will bring the city's
contribution to la county's vaccinations
to 20 000 people a day in our capacity
between dodger stadium and four city
operated sites and the fire stations
that are
vaccinating members of lafd and soon
other members of the city family
we are all collectively working around
the clock to get to more vaccines
more quickly but i think when folks are
confused out there the central issue is
we
simply aren't receiving enough vaccines
at the national level
and so i spoke with president-elect
biden yesterday
with his covet team as well and i know
that they are going to do everything
they can to work with manufacturers to
ramp that up because
here someone is infected every six
seconds
in los angeles and here in l.a somebody
is dying
every eight minutes every eight minutes
as terrible as those facts are we have
to celebrate good news when we see it
and that is with a vaccine
we can't drop our guard while this is
happening continue to keep your distance
wear your masks stay home
avoid gatherings get tested and you can
still get a free test every day of the
week
we are worried as we took this down as a
testing site to a vaccination site
whether we meet capacity and we are we
have and there are tests available today
at coronavirus.lacity.org
we're expanding capacity at eight sites
we're adding mobile teams
and we're building a new site at pierce
college in woodland hills
so again coronavirus.lacity.org testing
or by calling 311
you can still schedule a test while
we're addressing vaccination
with that let me move forward in our
program and our guests we've got
i know a bunch of questions that will
come from the press but please
hold with us because we've got some
really amazing folks and let me
first invite stan caston who is our host
here today to come forward and thank him
on behalf of a grateful city
a city that's celebrating still that we
will be the world champions until we
repeat that again
and no pressure for you stan but you
have been an amazing friend
thank you for you and we're so sorry for
your loss with tommy stan caston
thank you mayor um i moved here because
the mayor once told me that you know
it's
86 in january here people didn't believe
him but here we are
um i want to
express my thanks and appreciation to
all the people that the mayor mentioned
this
is only the result of so
many people having to pitch in but
you know adversity reveals who you are
none of us like adversity and
needless to say we have all lived
through
the worst year imaginable in terms of
adversity but
on the field the dodgers showed they
could overcome
that adversity and uh similarly off the
field we are very proud that
we've been able to show who we are
through adversity from becoming
america's la the world's largest covet
testing center
uh to becoming a
very large and important polling place
uh
in november to the drive through
christmas extravaganza that we had for
our community
and now today what is on its way to
becoming the world's largest
vaccination center
for 60 years this community has
supported the dodgers and so
we are pleased proud humbled and honored
to be able to support our community in
the same way that they support us so
as i said thank you to everyone who has
contributed
and participated in putting this
together
the dodgers will always be here to lend
a hand in any way that we can
we are not near the end yet but we are
getting nearer and we're getting there
every day and very soon
it'll be time for us to be playing ball
on these fields again
with our stands full and i hope i see
all of you there so
thank you very much now let me turn it
over to nuri
uh martinez our city council president
and thank you nuri for being such a
strong advocate for families during this
pandemic
thank you for being a great partner
please welcome our council president
thank you very much mr mayor
[Music]
and thank you i'm happy to be here with
the governor in mariogar city
both who have made extraordinary efforts
to respond to the pandemic
for so many angelenos this has been an
incredibly difficult year
and while we still have a long way to go
at least we know that
entering this new phase we now have a
vaccine and we can now start
having real hope and i say
that um fully recognizing the
responsibility
that we all have now the responsibility
to bring in hope not just as fast as
possible
but to as many of our hard hardest hit
communities
as possible this facility is one step
forward to doing that
in just a few days we're going to be
able to ramp up and deliver 12 000
vaccines a day that's right 12
000 vaccines a day but we have a lot
more work to do
because we have so many more people in
need
and that's where we must establish our
priorities
and we must make those shared priorities
not competing
with other priorities we have to have
shared priorities together
we need to get our healthcare workers
and our frontline workers vaccinated
we need to do right by them and we need
to make sure that they stay healthy
to get the rest of us through this
crisis but enough of this bureaucracy
we have the vaccine and as we roll it
out we need to deliver it to the most
vulnerable including our seniors
and i'll be damned if any of the vaccine
goes to waste
or gets thrown out simply because
we don't know how to follow regulations
or the confusing guidelines
or simply because somebody refuses to
take it
there are so many more folks that wanted
and need it today
there are so many lives at stake
i don't want this vaccine to go to waste
we have four million angelinos
including our essential workers and
people of color who deserve
immediate access to it and whether we do
it now
or or later some of those folks do not
have time to waste
it can mean life or death for them
when this site is open and others across
the city begin to open
in other parts of the state we need to
ensure
that we are addressing the hardest hit
communities and that we are talking
about
access to this vaccine the city is
committing
committed to making sure that our
residents have a place to get the
vaccine
as soon as a color we need to create
access in these neighborhoods that have
been hit the hardest
this is why last week i've asked the
city departments to take an
inventory of our city facilities to
ensure that we have
places to be able to distribute the
vaccine the facilities
should be concentrated in the highest
risk communities within our city and in
low-income communities of color
some say that goals of equity should be
set aside
and instead focus on getting more people
vaccinated
but if this year has taught us anything
it's that inequity
can no longer be ignored if we don't
focus on equity now
i'll tell you who's going to get the
vaccine it'll be the people
who have the luxury to stay at home and
send their children to open private
schools
and neighborhood learning pods and the
people who will not get the vaccine will
be the nannies
the maids the housekeepers and the
gardeners the people
who check out our groceries to prepare
our food every day who
deliver our mail and clean our clean our
streets
equity isn't about just checking off a
box
it's just isn't a word that you punch up
because you want to
create more media posts for yourselves
it's past time that we do right by these
neighborhoods and these communities and
these workers
and as difficult as it will be i know
that our governor
and our local elected officials here in
los angeles are committed to figuring
this out
as we roll out that vaccine we cannot
lose focus on distributing it quickly
but we also need to distribute it justly
as soon as possible
this is how we save lives in the most
vulnerable neighborhoods
this is how we thank our essential
workers for
risking their own lives on a daily basis
and this is how we ensure
that these neighborhoods are not left
behind yet again
there are workers throughout our city
and a lot of angelino stood in the store
steps clapping for our essential workers
and saying thank you for your service
but that cannot be enough
and we ignore the life-threatening risks
that they take
every single day during this pandemic we
are not that city we cannot allow that
to happen
for this past year i've been humbled to
lead the city council
that has focused on the working-class
families of our city
these are the people that we have been
fighting for every single day
the essential workers our seniors and
our children to keep them safe
so i look forward to working with our
governor and our mayor to make sure that
we prepare quickly to deliver this
vaccine to low-income
and immigrant communities throughout our
city
who do not have access to health
insurance these are the communities that
i represent
these are the communities that i will
continue to fight for and these are the
communities that i
ask you all to fight for as well
we're all in this together cannot just
be a slogan
for this vaccine to succeed it needs to
be a reality
thank you
thank you so much council president amen
amen
with that i don't need a talking point
to introduce
my friend and our state's leader a man
who i have seen and he comes from local
government so he knows what this
kind of a struggle to build something
like this looks like
a man who at a moment when the federal
government has been missing in action
has been not just california's governor
but america's governor and i want to say
because i know leadership at the top is
tough and it can be lonely
that we are so blessed in this golden
state
to have somebody with the intelligence
the drive
the grit and the heart that gavin newsom
brings to this we would not be here
today without him please welcome our
governor
gavin newsom
thank you mr mayor and thank you madam
president and congressman
senator and mr city council member all
of you
uh it's an honor to be here stan thank
you for once again
stepping up stepping in doing the right
thing thank you for being here
unselfishly for the entire community we
were here just a few months ago when
you opened this up as you noted uh for
early voting done it with food banks
you've done it
consistently in terms of the testing
regime and
sean and thank you guys the whole core
team for the incredible work
that you have done and assembling so
many volunteers and
extraordinary civic leaders leaders to
find people in positions of formal
authority but more importantly
people that are exercising their moral
authority and helping support
others that's the moment we're in we're
also in a moment of some urgency and let
me just be
quite candid with each and every one of
you we've got to increase the pace and
distribution in the administration
of these vaccines the reality is we need
to get these vaccines out of the freezer
and we need to get them into people's
arms
we need to make sure as the president
said we need to do that
with a lens of equity absolutely not
rhetorically we need to commit
and we need to be resolved in that
effort but we should not use that as an
excuse
not to move deliberatively uh and move
at the speed that this state
and our nation deserves at the end of
the day we
continue to battle this remarkable
moment in the surge the most difficult
and challenging surge
we have faced since the beginning of
this pandemic the good news is
we're starting to see light at the end
of the tunnel not just the light that
vaccines provide
but light as it relates to positivity
rate that's now declining
in the state of california case rates
that are now declining in the state of
california
hospitalizations that are now declining
in the state of california
icu admissions that are now declining in
the state
of california the last seven plus days
we have seen some encouraging signs but
now more than ever it's incumbent upon
us not to let our guard down not to let
our masks
off and to make sure that we're doing
everything in our power
to maintain that discipline that
purposefulness
uh to work our way through yet another
surge and so
we're here mindful that sober the
reality
that we face and the challenges that we
face as
a state and a nation uh but today is a
point
of emphasis point of optimism today uh
to celebrate
collaborative spirit celebrate
leadership to celebrate your mayor
uh for making sure that we raise the bar
in terms of expectation
and we deliver on what we're promoting
and promising i just want to say
uh to mayor garcetti uh he has been
steadfast
in his determination to get this site
open to get it operational and to come
down here
just days after we had a preliminary
conversation to see the incredible work
he and his team our firefighters
paramedics emts and
all those county partners including
those folks from usc and others
uh it's an extraordinary testament uh to
people with resolve with grit and
determination four thousand
people will get the vaccines today we
hope that's the goal
uh this is just day one the idea of
getting to 12 plus thousand
uh will be significant uh and will be a
logistics
opportunity not just a logistics
challenge dodger stadium is joining many
other mass vaccination sites
all throughout the state of california
is up at cal expo in sacramento
yesterday
much smaller site but with a same in
similar
mindset of throughput and moving these
and moving these and administering these
vaccines and moving
uh these vaccines out of the freezer and
getting them into people's arms we're
sitting down at petco
park and the padres uh joining the same
effort we're seeing it in the central
valley and fresno
at other fairground sites uh in the
central part of our state up in san
mateo
uh at a number of different facilities
and we are working with other
major league teams as well as minor
league teams to open up similar sites
as well all throughout the state of
california you should be seeing more
of this it's not exclusively what we're
doing
it's just additive we continue to want
to do more to provide
more access at pharmacies more access
with your doctor
more access for their primary care
physicians clinics
all throughout the spectrum of delivery
of our healthcare delivery system in the
state
we have 3 500 partners in the state of
california 3 500
providers that are distributing the
vaccine
because of waivers because of the
determined leadership and expectations
set by
the local leaders here we have waived
the ability for additional
administrators more vaccinators we have
over 100
000 people eligible to provide
vaccinations
15 national guard strike teams we have
dentists
now that can provide vaccines emts
paramedics
we have people across the spectrum in
our healthcare delivery system and
you're going to continue to see
more nursing students folks that are
retired coming back
in to the health corps and helping
provide and support
uh one another to date 1.188
million doses have been administered to
date 1.188 million doses
have been administered we are on pace to
exceed
our 1 million goal in 10 days
we'll update you more on that when the
dust settles on our data collection i
want
folks to be mindful that the numbers
that are often published and are out
there
are days old as so many providers
are submitting their information
providing that information
and ultimately that information is
provided to the federal government we're
looking to fast track that
with better urgency there's more
transparency in terms of where we are
but we recognize more transparency and
more application is the call at this
moment and so
i want californians to know it's like a
flywheel
we're making progress we're moving
deliberative speed and
may i say as mayor garcetti said how
significant it is
the fresh air of progress versus the
stale
air of normalcy the notion that we now
are being able to move forward
turn forgive me the proverbial page
working with a new administration
as early as next week the fruits of
their efforts and that transition takes
shape
and all of us will be the beneficiary of
that more
expectation more transparency on when
the doses will arrive
when we know when those thriving it
helps us with our planning purposes
it allows quicker and more efficient
throughput
more capacity to get returned phone
calls
to have people that truly are committed
bottom up
to delivering uh on this equity
measure and so i'm really looking
forward to that partnership and i want
to just express
appreciation just an hour or so ago
vice president now president-elect joe
biden announced
his strategy to prioritize people 65 and
over
his strategy for support for max
vaccination sites just like this
his strategy support uh the caregivers
and
support investments in our national
guard to help
with the distribution and administration
of the vaccines across
the board his plan mirrors the spirit
and the letter of our guidance here in
the state of camp
california so this is all encouraging
it's amplifying efforts that are all
already underway
and i just want to thank everybody for
all their extraordinary
work uh but again mindful always
of our responsibility each and every one
of you watching
to do more and do better to quickly
safely and efficiently mindful of equity
move these vaccines out of the
warehouses
out of the freezers into people's arms
you deserve
that and we are looking forward to
substantially improving
and increasing that effort in the days
weeks
and many many months ahead so thank you
all for being here
deep gratitude again to the mayor city
council
uh for their incredible leadership to
stand entire partnership here
at the lake dodgers for making this
extraordinary world-class site
available for this world-class logistics
operation
thank you
[Music]
thank you so much governor and and i
know you privately spoke about how proud
you are to have a california
championship team so thank you for that
uh
as well um we're gonna go to q a but we
have three extraordinary other people
and i can ask them just to keep their
their
their uh comments tight but they have
been critical
parts of this from the city council gil
sedillo whose district were in
the state senate uh steve bradford who
has led on equity statewide
as well as anybody i know and our
exceptional uh
member of congress so i asked the three
of them to come forward to say some
remarks
and then we'll answer questions from the
press and i'll come back and say some
things in spanish at the end
let's give them all round of applause
and thank them for being here too
i'll be your sprayer thank you
hi congressman jimmy gomez first let me
thank the governor
and the city council president marie
martinez as well as eric garcetti for
this this site
if you do the rough calculation just
back of the envelope calculation to vex
vaccinate every single person in la
county you would have to get up to about
a hundred thousand vaccinations a day
um throughout the county so we have a
and if you
do the math for the entire state it's
even bigger number
so we have a big challenge but i have no
doubt with
uh president-elect biden becoming the
president on january 20th
we're going to have a new not only a new
administration but i consider it a whole
brand new
year 2021 didn't start on the first
it's starting on january 20th
because it could be that much that
important that we have real leadership
in the white house
dealing with this pandemic and that's
what uh president biden
and vice president kamala harris are
going to do they're going to have the
the leadership and expertise to tackle
this
problem so i know that on day one he
will probably
call upon the defense production act to
get the necessary vaccinations
in production and out to people in the
states so we have a lot of work to do
but it's going to be a a challenge that
we're going to tackle
uh one uh from the top to the very
bottom and i have no doubt it's not only
could be a physical change
but it's gonna be a psychological change
where the american people
are going to stand up from the bottom of
their knees and stand up proud to once
again be american so
thank you so much and i want to just
thank everybody that's here thank you
thank you
come on forward don't worry i'll give it
a good spray
good afternoon senator steve bradford
representing the 35th senate district
but i'm honored to be here with
my good friend mayor garcia our governor
for the tremendous leadership that they
have provided on this issue not only
today but since the beginning and as a
member of the legislative black caucus
and now
new chair we want to make sure that this
is a priority it has always been a
priority not only for the black caucus
for the latino caucus for the women's
caucus
but especially for those people of color
as been stated
who are being impacted the most they are
our front line workers
they're our essential workers and we
want to make sure that they
not only are tested but get this vaccine
they're dying at a higher rate than
anyone else in this country
so this is critically important it will
be a priority under my leadership as
chair of the bloc caucus to work with
efforts such as this here at dodger
stadium again want to recognize the
great work
and uh partnership that dodger stadium
has provided
not only uh with testing but now with
this vaccination
and i just want it's not missed on me
today
would have been dr martin luther king's
92nd
birthday and i think he would be smiling
down today
understanding how we have come together
collaboratively
to make sure that equity
is distributed through our health care
system it's something that he fought for
during his lifetime and we're still
sadly still fighting for it
today so as we celebrate on monday
let's remember the words of dr martin
luther king we all can be great because
we all can serve let's make sure we get
out into our communities
and provide to services that necessary
to get these our constituents
vaccinated i also want to recognize dr
galley for his leadership and helping
the legislature in the state of
california and all that they do
and making sure that again we
get to the people who most need this all
people for that fact
but mostly people of color who are being
disenfranchised and being neglected so
again thank you for this opportunity
thank you sir
appreciate you
[Music]
cleaning up everything can be said has
been said
let me uh echo the eloquence of
the previous speakers attach myself to
them
governor thank you for your presence
thank you for your leadership
uh your presence says and sends an
incredible message to the community
that we are serious that we are capable
we are willing and able to solve this
problem
and it says to all of angelinos it's
time to step
up when the governor's here in town so
thank you governor appreciate your
presence
mayor thank you for your leadership as i
say
to you every time we have this
conversation
people don't know the the way the city
works and the way the county works
the city actually has no authority over
health care and i say that because
from the very beginning the mayor has
been the leader
in our efforts to combat this incredible
disease and so mayor thank you leaders
lead
uh obviously love you madam president
and thank you for your presence
making sure that our voices are heard
the question and the challenge of equity
in our society must be confronted
in every aspect of our lives and so i
thank you for that
happy birthday martin luther king he
said the measure of a man is not where
he stands at
comfort and convenience but where he
stands at conflict and controversy
i want to thank ann lee and sean pan for
your leadership
because when this conflict and
controversy emerged
you emerged with leadership with civic
responsibility civic duty
and embraced the challenges that have
confronted us without pause without
hesitation
without title without searching or
seeking fame or
notoriety you emerged as a partner in
this city
to address to address probably the
greatest
challenge health-wise that the city has
ever faced
and so thank you and thank all of you
for being here we've got tremendous work
to do but confidence
that we will go forward there is a light
at the end of the tunnel but we need to
embrace that
we need to run towards it it is our
solution and it is the resolution
it's a new day and it's a new time and
it's time for us and for the all
angelenos
to move forward and embrace the
opportunities
that exist for us thank you very much
and finally
without uh exception i can never step on
this field without saying
thank you to the great dodgers for their
civic participation
voting testing vaccines
and then championship baseball let's go
dodgers amen thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you i want to also give a shout
out to jeff gurrell and niraj and
everybody on my public safety team i
want to give a shout out to
secretary gali who was one of the best
things we've ever
exported from los angeles to sacramento
thank you for accepting some southerners
in the administration thank you naomi
rodriguez from the dodgers and everybody
else
made this happen with that we're happy
to answer questions and i'll give some
spanish remarks at the very end
as well and governor you may be uh
asking questions too so you might
probably want to come up
thank you yeah most of the press corps
had
questions for governor newsome so i'll
start with i'm happy to turn it over
mostly for you they said most of them
are for you but i'm behind you
yeah thank you man all right
governor newsom it was reported today
that
the federal government does not have a
stockpile of vaccines to send out
what does this mean for california's
supply of the vaccine
and does this mean california will not
be receiving any more shipments
when did you first learn of this and
have you spoken with
health and human services secretary alex
azar
um i have some more follow-up but we can
start there
yeah i know what we all heard about at
the same time i was talking to
some of my fellow governors we put out
statements that are that mirror one
another in terms of our disappointment
we had
an all governor's call with the vice
president
and uh hhs secretary 48 hours ago
uh making commitment and furthering
their resolve to
distribute these vaccines i was part of
a letter
a group of nine governors that requested
the vaccines particularly the 50 plus
million doses that were estimated
to be in storage in michigan be
distributed a few days later
hhs said they would be distributing
those doses
uh they confirmed that on the governor's
call and then we read as everybody else
uh that they have reneged on that or for
whatever reason
are unable to deliver on that we
already all of us are working closely
with the incoming administration and
hope and expectation we get some
clarification
uh in the absence of any further
clarification
by the current administration as soon as
we know
we'll be able to communicate that more
fully to
uh members of the public let me just say
though briefly
that our resolve is to get all of the
existing
doses that are in this state
administered as quickly and efficiently
as possible
and we still have a lot of work to do in
that space we look forward to getting
more
it will help us in our planning uh and
our distribution
but nonetheless we still have work to do
building more sites like this
to increase that throughput and how many
doses have you ordered and how many more
we have
we've received we've received and that's
the most important
number we've received just over 3
million doses
to date at least as of yesterday those
numbers get updated
in fact usually around this time i get
some additional information and we'll
provide that as we do on a daily basis
but 3 million
doses have been delivered to the state
how many more have you ordered we have
hundreds of thousands more
that we anticipate receiving but we now
obviously based on what we've heard in
the last 24 hours
want to confirm that those doses indeed
are available
and will arrive and that's why i
reinforce the three million number
what we've received it's now our
responsibility to get these 3 500
providers
up and down the state of california to
administer those vaccines in an
equitable manner but a very timely and
judicious way
your announcement that anyone 65 and
over was eligible to receive the vaccine
statewide admitted the reality that
counties would in fact decide when to
open up vaccinations to that age group
in their jurisdictions
many counties are still not ready what
do you say to elderly californians who
heard your announcement
left their homes visited pharmacies
potentially exposing themselves to the
virus
only to learn that what you said wasn't
entirely true and they were not eligible
to receive vaccines in their country
what i said was was absolutely true we
as a state
put out guidelines allowing for
flexibility
all across the state of california to
allow people 65
and over to have the vaccines
administered what we said
uh was clear as it relates to the
flexibility
within the tiers maintaining our
prioritization uh in
tier one a rather phase one a
and then beginning to tier into
phase 1b tier 1 and 2 75 and over
and 65 and over orange county has moved
to providing vaccinations forever 165
and over stanislaus
it's done the same i was talking to
merrick garcia down in long beach he's
moving
in that direction as well i think the
vast majority of our counties will be
moving very very shortly
in that direction the purpose was
crystal clear and that is to make sure
the guidelines
were not barriers and to provide the
flexibility with the sense of urgency
that's needed in this moment and we were
heartened to see
the president-elect double down on that
call for 65 and over as well
why did you delegate responsibility of
the vaccination process
to counties without providing adequate
resources to do a vaccination
program smoothly and efficiently well we
provided substantial resources i have a
budget includes
372 million dollars additional
resources just for vaccinations that's
not part of the testing and tracing
program we have an additional 1.7
billion dollars in the new budget we
submitted just this time last week on
friday
for that purpose this builds on the work
we did with the legislature last year
to provide resources right now uh it's
not
uh resources it's a resourcefulness it's
a mindset and that's why we've been
moving in the last week
to provide more uh ability for
vaccinators meaning provide
more uh categories of vaccinators over
now 100
000 people eligible to vaccinate why
we've been working hard with cities and
counties
including la city and county to get this
site up and operational it's why
uh we announced uh the work that's being
done
not just at fairgrounds uh on the coast
up and down the state of california but
in the inland part of the state so it's
a flywheel and we're working
aggressively to increase points of
access
and increase more transparency and
accountability for those 3 500 partners
and providers all throughout the state
of california that are entrusted to
deliver these vaccines to administer
these vaccines given reports that
there's
no federal stockpile as expected will
california have enough doses for those
who are due for their second shot in the
next few days and weeks
will counties have to pull back from
vaccinating people 65 and up
yeah we we don't see any at the moment
dr galley's here and dr kelly can run up
here uh
if he has any additional thoughts to say
on this but we don't see any
issues at the moment as it relates to
second doses
we've distributed over and rather
administered over 200
000 second doses to date in the state at
least as of last night
we are starting to receive second doses
and we believe the second doses will
be available based upon what we have
been assured
by the federal administration that said
uh
we are now mindful of the importance to
verify
uh that information uh even more uh with
more acuity
but current moment doctor i don't think
the second dose issue
is an issue in this state he concurs
i just want to get this in as this has
been asked by many people what's your
response to the one million people
who've signed the petition to recall you
uh did did you or anyone on your
political team advise the california
democratic party to refer to the recall
effort as a coup yeah i'm focused on
vaccine distributions i'm here
with uh deep pride and respect uh
for the people that made this mass
vaccination site possible
that's my focus that's where my energy
is going and so that's
why i'm here uh with confidence and
expectation and we'll build on the work
that's been done here
and we can replicate sites like this up
and down the state of california
do you disagree with the
characterization of it as a coup
as it relates to the issue of
vaccinations it relates to issue of
testing
isolation and tracing getting the state
moving again
reopening our businesses reopen our
schools that's the
focus that's where my energy is where
i'll be putting
most of my time and respectfully not
focusing on those issues
do you have any timeline on when
teachers will start to receive vaccines
they're in the tiered status updates
last week you may recall
we provided the first phase of
clarifications as it relates to
flexibility
within phases and tears teachers
are in that flex plan teachers can
be provided those vaccines based upon
availability again we're still
prioritizing healthcare workers people
in congregate facilities
skilled nursing facilities assisted
living facilities and residential
facilities
but the next tier has opened up
phase 1b it's referred to and
it provides for teachers farm workers
food
service industry and those 75
and over i remind you the idea is pretty
simple here and i think
the president summed it up very nicely
the idea we don't want to see any
vaccines
wasted we want to see them administered
efficiently
and we're providing some clarification
again try not to
create hurdles create barriers provide
flexibility
and that flexibility has now been
provided
in these updated health orders and the
guidelines we put out
and that includes teachers so why are we
seeing
some counties are getting to the 1b
phase quicker than others
uh for example even long beach city has
moved quicker than the rest of the
county that's right a lot
a lot of places reality is we're many
parts
but one body and the fact is 58 counties
470 almost 480 cities
in the state different leadership
different methodology in terms of focus
and energy
a different ideology and so in each and
every case
it's different the state of california
has received not one dose
of the vaccine the state of california
doesn't directly administer the vaccine
that's done through a network
of providers not dissimilar to the
network that's well established here in
the state of california
that advances and administers up to 19
million flu
vaccines each and every year that's done
through a myriad of providers as i said
just in state of california over 3 500
providers
la county it's over 1200 roughly
1200 providers plus or minus in that
range and so
some are excelling some are doing
extraordinary job
and some uh have a mindset where they're
going to be a little more methodical
a little more focused here's the good
news we're in constant communication
with the counties and we are constantly
working through what the issues are what
their challenges are trying to be
resourceful we've
provided almost 2 600 staff members
to the cities and counties over the last
number of months
federal as well as state resources we
provided more flexibility in terms of
those that can vaccinate i noted
uh the efforts around paramedics emts
and dentists and noted that there's over
a hundred thousand
individuals who can do the same national
guard not only are they
protecting state capital and state uh
resources but they're also
at food banks today they're also working
in mass vaccination sites
all up and down the state of california
so we're working through those issues
and
i'm confident in the next days and weeks
particularly with the new administration
setting the bar at 65 and older
that the vast majority of counties will
be moving very very quickly in that
direction
california has one of the slowest rates
of vaccination
of its population is the strict
prioritization of who gets the vaccine
first
why this rate is so low well that's one
of the reasons we've
made very clear abundantly clear the
shift in flexibilities
the ability to toggle between phase one
a
and phase one b tier one tier two why
we're opening these mass distribution
sites
uh why we now have significantly
increased our administration just the
last seven or eight days we put out an
audacious goal
a stretch goal of one million vaccines
administered within 10 day period 100
000 plus a day goal will be
substantially greater in february
and march uh we're well on our way to
meeting that goal and so we're making
tremendous progress and we're down here
uh extending a narrative that
promotes even more progress in the
coming not weeks
but the coming days as well
can you provide any details about the
national guards troops you
requested to secure the state capitol
when they will arrive and whether this
was in coordination with president trump
uh it was not been in coordination with
the current administration
it was done at least president that is
it was done though in coordination
with our federal partners at all levels
from the fbi on down we have a joint
operations center in the state of
california
we look at all of the intel with our
federal partners with our state partners
some international partners
as well we adjudicated those facts not
dissimilar to
what has been adjudicated in other
states governors uh of all political
stripes have substantially increased
their security
posture moving into nut just next week
in the inaugural on the 20th but also
through this
weekend uh we did the same i signed an
order yesterday general order providing
up to 1 000
uh national guard men and women to be
deployed
critical assets crept them down the
state not just the state capital
we other put other security measures
perimeter measures
in place with respect i'm not going to
go into detail about those measures
would be inappropriate uh from a
security perspective uh but rest assured
we've taken this very very seriously and
we're very grateful to the partnership
uh that we have received with our
federal partners
in law enforcement and the intel we've
gathered locally uh not just at the
state level
thank you so much governor newsome and i
i do have turning it back to garcetti
now
a couple more questions god bless oh
yeah more for me uh sorry uh
we're we are gonna i think move to mayor
garcia excellent good
good that's the spirit
hi hi mayor garcetti
with dodger stadium able to dole out 12
000 vaccinations per day
and the other supersites opening on
tuesday adding a total of another 20 000
per day
will the county have enough of the
vaccine to keep up with the demand
the short answer is i don't know i hope
so and i spoke with dr ferrer last night
and right now we think we can hold on to
that but the result of that has been i
know some pharmacies that the county had
hoped to disperse more
vaccines to have to wait a week because
the national supply simply isn't coming
it's not a
problem with the state it's not a
problem here locally we simply don't
have the supply coming in
but we do believe that those what i was
told last night is with those five sites
each one of the supervisorial districts
and this
that we can sustain both those this
coming week for sure
do you support mandatory vaccinations
for los angeles firefighters
um i hope every los angeles firefighter
gets a vaccine
at this point we don't need to mandate
that
i think early on in this whether you're
a healthcare worker or firefighter
you absolutely should to protect folks
and to stop spread
but early on if folks are saying no and
have a declination form move on to the
next folks
and there's a lot of people waiting
right now who are high risk of dying
those folks over 65 people living in
particular neighborhoods without breaks
so i don't mind moving on there and i
think for a lot of people as they see
people
two or three months in with no effect
and being able to
reintegrate into society there will be
even more pressure and we'll get those
numbers even higher
but right now no we're not mandating it
so
several months down the line if it turns
out that many firefighters have not
gotten the vaccine
will you look into making it mandatory
potentially and with our city workers
it's something that we're talking about
especially those who will be interacting
with the public
look i think there's going to be a lot
of things that push people towards that
for instance you probably can't get in
dodger stadium for the first games if
you haven't been vaccinated
go to concerts do some of the things
that are part of
what we do uh as we reopen the economy
so i think there's gonna be a lot of
incentive for people as they see how
safe they are how effective they are
that if they held back that they will
join that
um and just a point of clarification my
understanding is the
the javits center in new york has the
capacity to do
25 000 vaccinations per day so in terms
of whether or not this is
supposed to be the the largest in the in
the country do you have more information
on that
yeah they have that capacity they're not
doing anywhere near that um and
uh that that's if they ran a 24 7
operation
similarly if we run a 24 7 operation
here we can exceed that
this will be the biggest um frank
mccourt who as i understand owns the
dodgers stadium parking lot um
is is he charging the city of los
angeles for use of this as a coveted
testing vaccination site and he's been a
great partner nope
and so that's just being given for free
absolutely this is really to him to the
dodgers it's been all done
at no cost we have stepped up and
shouldered a lot of the cost uh but our
conversation with the county and
um with incoming administration one of
the things that the incoming
administration is talking about is 100
fema reimbursement for folks like our
national guard at the state level
um i encouraged um the kind of kovidzar
jeff science to do the same thing uh
with the biden administration's
proposals for firefighters and
other city and county workers that are
essentially doing the same thing
and this is for you um or a public
health official
whoever feels more comfortable answering
um
if necessary if people do not get their
second dose
um immediately in other words if more
than three or four weeks elapses is that
okay
if necessary to wait to give people
their second doses until months later
uh when we have more doses is that okay
i will always say i'm not a doctor first
but yes i learned last night from our
fire
assistant chief foreman that the
guidance has come out on pfizer
that if you don't hit the exact date
that it's fine if you go a week or two
later
and it is the expectation that that will
happen with moderna too
that should not let us ex accept that
the vaccines are coming too slowly but
for folks worried that somehow your arm
will expire or the first dose will
expire
i want to all the evidence and all the
information i've been given is saying
that's not the case and that's already
come out officially up from from pfizer
about the pfizer vaccine
and how exactly do you propose uh
workers handle doses that are left over
at the end of the day at
city vaccination sites so i was uh you
know as i mentioned i worked the the
line coming in i
worked with the pharmacist they and and
i did a bottle myself so
you can get about 10 doses at
the dosage level for the moderna ones
and there's really nothing left there
you can't combine that less than a
single dose
because you take your syringe out expose
it to the air and by putting it to
another bottle and that is not
acceptable right now in a hospital
clinical setting that is done sometimes
from different bottles but 100 of
a full dosage is being taken out of each
one of these bottles here
so if there's something left it's less
than a dose
okay and so can you just clarify if
you're going to create a specific
policy for what happens if if there are
leftover doses somehow no we don't we
don't create that because we're not a
health department we don't have a health
department we don't have jurisdiction on
that but we follow the guidance and i
know that the public health department
of the county put out that guidance that
nothing should be wasted
uh certainly as i said last night in my
press conference use common sense
if uh if there's somebody who's been
working the line uh who's a volunteer
at the end of the day and it's gonna be
uh gone put it in somebody's arm
and instead of throwing it out and i and
i think the department of public health
at the county level made very clear
there's absolutely no guidance to throw
out what's left at the end of the day
what we're going to do i think in sites
like this is figure out a way to quickly
communicate to people who are eligible
who can come with little notice and come
quickly to use whatever's left
and are you going to be standing up
other mass vaccination sites besides
dodger stadium
we hope to uh absolutely we're ready to
um initially the county had asked us to
look at expo park i don't think they're
going to
change that from a testing center right
now though that would be another great
place
um so our fire department has already
have the contingency plans to move to
other places we're looking at those
sites
as soon as we get the supply and the
county says we need more help just as we
did with testing
we are ready to act you see this
turnaround time i i texted the governor
what was it five six days ago about this
and we're standing here today i mean it
was less than yeah
we did this in just over a week's time i
think maybe 10 days max
so this department again we say it and
it sounds like something that
politicians just say it is an
exceptional
department that knows how to figure this
out core
is an exceptional organization and the
friendship and the working relationships
they have together
i think makes this a partnership unlike
anything else in the country
all right thank you so much thank you
all right that and of all questions
okay i'm going to say a couple things in
spanish and then we are
finding shade all of us um
and i promise it's not the full speech
[Music]
hola estamos aqui en el estado de los
dos para transformar lo que asido el
mayor centro de puebas
thanks everybody thanks for bearing with
the heat
[Music]
you